death is in the air
oswald
the future king of east anglia has
fallen
killed by a rogue dane army
he was the only man with the vision to
unify this kingdom
land where saxons and danes may live
together in peace
for that vision
we go to war
if ruiz clan continues to roam this
kingdom unchecked the people of east
anglia will be as ravaged as these lands
and where we find ourselves riding into
defense to beg a horde of frightened
farmers for aid to fight for a king that
you gave them vineyard remember that it
was my task to find them a king not
protect that king against every danger
that might be fallen oswald wasn't
crowned yet nor was he married
i say you have some work yet to do
right right no need to remind me how far
i felt short
watch your back lord's clan may still be
nearby
what did you expect brother sword and
silver we had a bit of fun that's what
matters
[Music]
ruins men are a blight on this land
blight is too kind of word a serious
curse
come back
what the
did all this
ruins clan is your enemy not me i come
on behalf of the late oswald of elmenham
you're still a gain from top to two but
your meddling that led to oswald's death
leaving our kingdom for the worse
east anglia will fall if ruiz clan is
not defeated fight with me to drive them
off for oswald and your kinsmen
pretty words dying but the men of
thiovard have their own battles to fight
if you need an axe i'm standing right
here
there's a village to the east kingsbury
it was taken by ruin's men a fortnight
ago
and oil not rest until it's back in our
hands
let me and my raiders take the village
save your strength and join us for the
fight to come
bold offer
if you do as you promise
the pikes that they have art will be
yours
i will take this news to our forward
campaign follow where you can
i will see you there
kingsbury's church has a great horror
and a topic steeple
if you manage the task blew it i'll knew
you kept your word
a word if you will
you called to me we heard you talking
with the reeve and we wish to fight
beside you
we owe oswald for his good deeds and
fair rule i'm glad to hear it go to the
ruins north of berg castle the army
gathers there
have you seen mother oh blessed your
mother
when was lost you saw her
before the bad man came
right back
manuals
run up here
[Music]
festive
tower
ah
[Music]
give up
be wary of tricks
um
ah
oh
[Music]
um
victory
so
ah
uh
so
the reeve has come to join me
let's hope his promise holds
the horn
it's been so long since i've earned that
sweep i held to my oath reeve i hope you
will honor yours my promise holds i
they avoid will join you in the fight
against ruid's clan with your aid we may
yet save east anglia in past times that
horn was used to muster fears all across
our land
you may find others who have warmed to
its call
good
whatever willing men you find rally them
soon at the ruins north of bird castle
theo board has answered the call
i